[Musik]
im lockdown lernt man sein zuhause
richtig schätzen
doch wenn die wohnung klassenzimmer und
büro auch noch rein passen müssen dann
hätte man gern ein paar quadratmeter
mehr bezahlbaren mietwohnungen sind aber
noch immer mangelware vor allem in
großen städten die wohnraum offensive
der bundesregierung die will das ändern
verspricht mehr neubau mehr sozialen
wohnungsbau und es gibt ja auch noch das
baukindergeld heute gab es eine erste
bilanz dazu deutschland ist mieter land
und über den traum vom eigenheim wird
auch wieder neu diskutiert brauchen wir
neue konzepte für die eigenen vier wände
luxus wohnen wer kann sich das noch
leisten unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
ich bin jetzt beim vierten bundeskanzler
in der regierung sondern in der politik
da helmut schmidt habe ich das noch
erlebt und kohl und gerhard schröder und
angela merkel und ich kann nur sagen ein
solches impulsprogramm für die
wohnungswirtschaft habe ich nicht erlebt
der bundesbauminister der lobt sich
selbst aber wie ist es mit denen die
bauen wollen und mit denen die wohnungen
brauchen und was sagt die opposition
darüber sprechen wir hier mit diesen
gästen lukas siebenkotten es bei uns
erst präsident des deutschen
mieterbundes schönen guten abend und ich
begrüße ganz herzlich marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann bundestagsabgeordnete
der fdp und mitglied im ausschuss für
bauen wohnen und stadtentwicklung und
zugeschaltet ist uns axel gedaschko er
ist seit zehn jahren präsident des
bundesverbandes deutscher wohnungs und
immobilienunternehmen gdw und zuvor war
er wirtschaftssenator in hamburg
guten abend und ich begrüße caren lay
von der linken
sie ist sprecherin für mieten bau und
wohnungspolitik ihrer fraktion show
guten abend fräulein 7 konnte
siebenkotten wir haben es gesehen der
bundesbauminister ist ja zufrieden er
hat ja versprochen 1,5 millionen neue
wohnungen zu bauen und er nimmt auch
kräftig geld in die hand nämlich fünf
milliarden für den sozialen wohnungsbau
das muss den mieterbund doch freuen
ja hat angekündigt zu beginn der
legislaturperiode 1,5 millionen
wohnungen bauen lassen zu können
aber es werden nur knapp 1,2 millionen
natürlich ist das schon ein bisschen was
aber es ist das ziel deutlich verfehlt
und er ist ein ganz trickreich oder man
könnte auch sagen schlitzohrig und
rechnet baugenehmigungen dazu von denen
aber noch gar keiner gebrauch gemacht
hat und bekannt nicht kann man in einer
baugenehmigung nicht wohnen und insofern
kann man die auch nicht dazu rechnen
zumal viele von diesen baugenehmigungen
möglicherweise eher aus spekulativen
gründen zurückgehalten werden das heißt
deswegen nicht gebaut wird weil
derjenige der die baugenehmigung hat gar
nicht bauen will
und insofern finde ich die bilanz
nicht so großartig wenn man das selbst
gesteckte ziel mit der überschrift
wohnraum offensive nicht erreicht er
geht das so was mal was fehlt es denn
wenn er
siebenkotten sagt dass da wird noch
nicht genug gebaut würden sie gerne mehr
bauen könnten sie mehr bauen der mit
herr seehofer sein ziel erreicht wir
können die anträge stellen sensibel ist
ja eine gemeinsame veranstaltung des
gehören dazu die kommunen es gehören
dazu die bundesländer und es gehört der
bund natürlich dazu so will ich mir das
an ziehe was unsere unternehmen in
deutschland leben dann fehlt es erstmals
schon an den bauplätzen
es fehlt an bau kapazitäten vielfach
könnten wir gar nicht mehr bauen selbst
wenn wir es wollten
es fehlt an die genehmigungs kapazitäten
jetzt gerade auch in den helm dann also
digitalisierung in vielen ämtern
mangelware bzw
totale fehlanzeige und dann fehlt es für
einigen an einem es fehlt auch an
unterstützung für den sozialen
wohnungsbau
wir haben in deutschland einen fall von
43.000 wohneinheiten gerade jetzt im
letzten jahr gehabt aus dem bereich des
sozialen wohnungsbaus und wir haben dazu
gekommen in etwa 25.000 also die
rechnung die besagt wir brauchen im jahr
ungefähr 80.000 geht hinten und vorne
nicht auf ok aber ich würde den ball
gern weiterspielen an frau laudan jetzt
heißt es aber doch ist der soziale
wohnungsbau wird sehr verstärkt es gibt
da richtig der bund nimmt ordentlich
geld dafür in die hand das ist doch erst
mal ein sehr positives zeichen
naja also dass herr sehen frau merkel
sich heute präsentieren vor allem mit
guten ergebnissen das ist jetzt
natürlich im vorfeld des wahlkampfes
normal
aber es entspricht leider nicht den
fakten wenn herr seehofer sagt werden
sehr schöne ergebnisse beim sozialen
wohnungsbau
die wahrheit ist die der soziale
wohnungsbau in deutschland befindet sich
wirklich auf einem historischen
tiefstand von gerade mal etwas über
einer million sozial
es sind alleine in dieser
legislaturperiode unterm strich circa
160 tausend sozialwohnungen weggefallen
das waren immer deutlich mehr
sozialwohnungen aus der bindung als neu
gebaut werden und da muss man sagen dass
die regierung sich da ein positives
zeugnis ausstellt das kann ich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen zumal obwohl wir
diese wohnungskrise haben die
bundesregierung erst im letzten jahr die
ausgaben für den sozialen wohnungsbau
gekürzt hat um ein ganzes drittel und
die bundesrepublik gibt insgesamt gerade
mal so viel geld für den sozialen
wohnungsbau aus wie die stadt wien
alleine und das ist wirklich völlig
ungenügend wurde da frau
strack-zimmermann auch die fdp mit gehen
zu sagen wir brauchen auf jeden fall
mehr sozialen wohnungsbau oder sagen sie
eigentlich müsste man es auf eine andere
art schaffen dass wohnungen bezahlbar
sind beides wir brauchen wir sozialen
wohnungsbau das ist in der tat richtig
wir haben verwerfungen in großstädten
der druck auf die großstädte ist immens
das was herr seehofer gesagt hat will
ich nicht kommentieren das ist von allen
völlig richtig kommentiert worden es ist
jetzt natürlich tralala vor der
bundestagswahl
das darf er die realität ist dass die
städte und kommunen bisher alleine
gelassen worden gerade der druck auf die
städte wie ich sagte ist immens
es ist zu wenig fläche der die menschen
wollen in der stadt wohnen aus vielen
gründen und der rumpf legt deswegen wir
haben seinerzeit in düsseldorf das ist
die stadt aus der ich komme ein
handlungskonzept wohnen entwickelt erst
mal ein kommunales dass jeder der mehr
als 100 wohneinheiten gebaut mindestens
40% sozial oder preis gedämpft baupreis
gedämpft ist für die gruppe von menschen
die nicht mehr in die kategorie sozialer
wohnungsbau fallen weil sie einen tick
mehr verdienen aber zu wenig haben um
sozusagen auf dem freien markt sich
austoben zu können
das hat sich ziemlich bewährt aber um
direkt auf den bund zurück zu kommen der
bund selber hat eine menge grundstücke
ich nenne jetzt mal das beispiel wo
keine kaserne sind die man sehr gut
umwandeln könnte ins in basel lanciert
aber die preise die der bund aufwirft in
den kommunen anbietet ist unterirdisch
oder besser gesagt überirdisch hoch das
heißt richtig wäre wenn die beamer also
der das grundstück gehört
das anbietet zu einem solchen preis es
die kommunen selber oder mit partnern
genossenschaften auch wohnungen
errichten könnten das wäre der richtige
weg also allein fünf milliarden macht es
nicht sondern da gibt es deutlich mehr
stellschrauben ich bin allerdings vor
dass der bund sich dieses themas endlich
mal annimmt weil in der tat kann man den
sieger wurden hier im september 20 18
formuliert dieser wohnraum offensive ist
ja schon so dass es jetzt klar es ist
auf der agenda stehe wir was einfach
gemacht werden muss wir haben druck und
wenn druck entsteht müssen wir deutlich
mehr bauen wir müssen verdichten und wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir wohnungen
entstehen damit auch der druck auf den
mietmarkt nach listen ganz kurz er
gedacht wenn frau strack zimmermann sagt
man muss preis gedämpft eben dann bauen
also für die leute die etwas mehr
verdienen also die für den sozialen
wohnungsbau nicht in anmerkung kommen
lohnt sich das für sie als
immobilienwirtschaft zu bauen für
menschen die nicht so viel geld haben
oder der bundesfinanzminister hat heute
auch gesagt baut wohnungen für alle die
wenig geld haben machen sie das dann
verdienen sie noch genug daran der
königsklasse weil teuer bauen kann jeder
die frage ist nur wenn jetzt zum
beispiel die grundstückspreise entsteht
zwischen 100 200.000 einwohnern sich in
den letzten zehn jahren vervierfacht
haben können sie da einfach nicht mehr
so bauen dass otto normalverbraucher die
möglichkeit hat da bezahlbar einzuziehen
das ist das dilemma dass wir haben das
heißt wir brauchen trotzdem preiswerten
grund und boden auch für diese klasse
die nicht sozial und heißt und dann ist
die frage eben auch der kosten die
einmal aussprechen muss wir haben 75
prozent plus zwischen 2000 und 2020 bei
den baukosten die einkommensentwicklung
liegt so bei etwa 35 prozent in dieser
zeit und dass man eigentlich dieses
dilemma problem bestehen deutlich wir
versuchen darauf zu reagieren indem wir
beispielsweise serielles bauen wieder
einführen wir haben einen europaweiten
wettbewerb gemacht für unser unternehmen
die preise sind etwas günstiger
aber es war das erste mal dass so etwas
wieder überhaupt in deutschland gemacht
wurde da muss man gas gegeben werden
wünschen dass das auch weiter
unterstützen wird durch den bund da
müssen wir ausdrücklich sagen das hat
der bunten mit unterstützen das rechnet
weber an
aber da sind wir erst ganz am anfang
genauso verhält es sich im übrigen wenn
wir über bezahlbare wohnungen bauen
reden für die energetische sanierung der
steuer ist dann müssen wir auch in die
serielle fertigung kommen auf jeden fall
noch noch dazu gehört aber noch mal ganz
kurz ist bauen immer noch etwas womit
man gut geld verdienen kann in diesem
land für die breite masse also es gibt
viele unternehmen die von ihnen sogar
sehr gut damit
sie wollen ihr allerdings nicht bei uns
haben wir das sind insbesondere die
unternehmen die von cayman islands und
co kommen die jetzt natürlich die chance
wintern in einem überhitzten markt um
wasserpreise zu nehmen also die gibt es
und von deiner das gehört eben auch zu
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft muss das
tun auch gebändigt werden
siebenkotten wer profitiert im moment am
meisten von dem mietwohnungsmarkt also
es profitieren diejenigen die mit einem
relativ hohen einkommen ausgestattet
sind und sich eine teurere wohnung
leisten können
man muss es umgekehrt betrachten wo ist
das problem das problem ist da das für
die menschen die wenig geld im
portemonnaie haben einfach nicht das
genügende angebot daher sind welchem
segment ist der mangel an größten
eindeutig in dem bereich des unteren
finanziellen drittels der der
bevölkerung wobei man sagen muss in
manchen universitätsstädten und
metropolen ist das problem schon in der
mitte der gesellschaft angekommen und
betrifft nicht nur die leute die relativ
wenig geld in der tasche haben das muss
man klar sagen aber die sind die die
gebissen werden weil das ist so wenn zu
wenig wohnungen da sind reagiert der
markt natürlich damit dass die mieten zb
steigen das ist ganz logisch und dann
sind diejenigen die wenig geld haben
natürlich diejenigen die dann die miete
höher die höhere miete nicht mehr
leisten können nicht mehr schaffen
können wir haben heute die
station dass viele menschen im unteren
einkommenssegment fast 50 prozent ihres
verfügbaren netto haushaltseinkommens
für die miete aufwenden müssen für das
wohnen aufwenden müssen gesund wäre
unter 33 also unter einem drittel
und das ist auch zur zeit der
durchschnitt aber es gibt sehr viele
menschen mit geringem einkommen die das
gar nicht stemmen können und deshalb ist
unter anderem gibt es eine mietpreis
bremse es gibt einen mieten deckel ist
gewieft fordern einen mieten stoff also
da müssen wir vielleicht erst mal ein
bisschen ordnung in all diese
forderungen bringen wo ganz klar ist es
geht darum dass die mieten nicht
exorbitant steigen
ja also das muss man auseinanderhalten
der mietpreis bremse gibt es seit ein
paar jahren sie betrifft ausschließlich
neuvermietung und wiedervermietung also
jemand schließt mietvertrag neu ab sie
betrifft nicht den zeitraum in dem der
mietvertrag im bestand ist und die
weitaus meisten menschen ziehen pro jahr
nicht um oder wir haben auch keine neue
mietwohnung sondern bleiben in ihren
eigenen vier wänden und die
mietsteigerungen die damit verbunden
sind sind von der bundesregierung in den
letzten jahren nicht angepackt worden
außer bei der energetischen
modernisierung und deswegen haben wir da
ganz besonders große probleme
dann gibt es den mieten stoppt die
initiative mieten stoppt die wir mit
anderen zusammen ins leben gerufen haben
die schlägt vor für eine zeit für einen
zeitraum von mehreren jahren die mieten
nicht steigen zu lassen also dass die
gleich bleiben müssen alle mieten
das ist ein zivilrechtliches system das
würde am bgb anknüpfen und das dritte
ist der mieten deckel 10 gehen es in
berlin gehe jetzt seit einem jahr und da
ist ein öffentlich rechtliches system
ist ein bisschen kompliziert aber eher
begrenzt immerhin mieterhöhungen für
rund 90 prozent der berliner wohnung so
ist macht es sinn wenn man sagt wir
brauchen wohnungen für das untere
drittel für das für die bürger die sich
eben nicht so viel leisten kann das
untere drittel dass man sagt ja man muss
auf jeden fall diese mieten begrenzen
weil sonst kann
sich das niemand mehr leisten also das
sind jetzt sehr viele themen die
zusammen geworfen worden sind ich würde
das gerne mal ab schichten erstmal das
thema das natürlich die die am wenigsten
haben am meisten betroffen sind bin ich
völlig bei ihnen aber es geht ja noch
weiter es geht ja in die breite mitte
der gesellschaft wenn sie also vor
jahren ich nehme doppelverdiener mann
frau die gut verdienen selbst für die
ist der wohnungsmarkt inzwischen so aus
den fugen dass sie eben in der relation
was sie gerade sagten zu nettogehalt
inzwischen geld auf den tisch legen und
das ist nicht gesund das heißt aber das
muss man ja doch wieder steuerlich
wollten einmal sei es ist nicht nur ein
problem der die wenig haben sondern es
geht wirklich in die breite der
gesellschaft
deswegen ist es auch gut dass wir
darüber diskutiert dass das eine das
zweite ist der weg dahin
wissen sie der mieten deckel in berlin
der klingt erst mal toll aber er
betrifft natürlich auch viele leute die
eine mögliche erhöhung der mieten
durchaus bezahlen könnten
das heißt man will der einen gruppe
etwas gutes tun und belohnt die anderen
die man gar nicht belohnen müsste das
ist das erste dann seitdem dieser dieser
wir haben ja eine normenkontrollklage
auf den weg gebracht weil wir glauben
dass das rein rechtlich gar kein nicht
haltbar ist sie haben nämlich jetzt ein
schwarzmarkt der sich entwickelt hat
erstmal sind viel weniger wohnungen auf
dem markt hier kann man bei in berlin
war nämlich viele die eine
eigentumswohnung haben sie sie vermietet
haben sagen dass es mir hier zu heiss
mache ich nicht mehr verkaufe ich das
heißt sie haben objektiv seitdem weniger
mietangebote und ein letztes und das ist
ganz spannend dieser schwarzmarkt das
sozusagen leute um eine wohnung zu
bekommen plötzlich für küche und möbel
extra bezahlen müssen also eine summe
zusätzlich auf den tisch legen das
kriegt gar keiner mit die aufs jahr
umgelegt eine höhere miete lehrer das
heißt das dass ein eingriff ist der
licht wirkt klingt ganz toll aber ist
nicht dass wir brauchen wir brauchen
mehr wohnungen wir müssen bauen wir
müssen von den standard ist ja immer die
frage wenn man auch mehr wohnungen hat
auch diese wohnungen werden ja da wird
ja auch eine miete vorher festgelegt
rolle warum finden sie diese mietpreis
bremsen den mieten deckel auch in berlin
eine initiative der linken warum finden
sie das richtig und gut weil wir alleine
mit einer politik bauen
warum bauen das problem nicht in den
griff bekommen können
wir haben ja schon alleine deswegen weil
das ja mehrere
jahre dauert bis eine wohnraum offensive
tatsächlich greift das sehen wir jetzt
auch dass die selbst die bundesregierung
an selbst gesteckten zielen scheiterte
also wir müssen glaube anfang meist
wohnen wir brauchen einmal mehr neubau
vor allen dingen im bezahlbaren bereich
also für menschen machen sondern höher
durchschnittsverdiener und
durchschnittsverdiener rinnen aber wir
brauchen eben auch eine regulierung der
mietpreisentwicklung wie es übrigens in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik immer
wieder stattgefunden hat also dass wir
jetzt sagen das ist ein großes novum
das ist jetzt wirklich eine eher
kurzsichtige historische perspektive das
hat hier suche ich immer gegeben und
zwar aus guten gründen denn man muss ja
auch sagen dass die wohnung ja auch
jetzt sich irgendeinen handels
gegenstand ist auch wenn das sicherlich
einige zu sehen sondern vor allen dingen
ist ja das zuhause von menschen und dass
wir vieles ist aber auch eine alte
verdrängt wurden es ist für viele worte
altersvorsorge frau sei dass viele leute
haben sich ja nach dem krieg auf wieder
ja um viel um ihre altersvorsorge
aufzubessern
genau ich bin jetzt erst mal aus der
sicht der menschen die in diesen
wohnungen leben für die dass das zuhause
ist und die ihre wohnung nicht aufgeben
wollen
und es ist wirklich eine ganz traurige
geschichte das wirklich sehr sehr viele
menschen aus den wohnungen verdrängt
wurden aus in denen sie zum teil
jahrzehnte gelebt haben und dass der
staat hier nicht gehandelt hat das ist
wirklich sehr sehr stimmt das thema
altersvorsorge das nehme ich sehr ernst
ich glaube nicht dass wir die interessen
der mieterinnen und mieter und der
kleinen vermieter die vielleicht eine
altersvorsorge haben gegeneinander
ausspielen lassen also auch an
funktionierenden wohnungsmarkt würde das
funktionieren und das hat historisch
auch funktioniert das problem aus meiner
sicht ist es tatsächlich diese großen
wohnungskonzern vor allen dingen das
private equity fonds hedgefonds auf den
wohnungsmarkt getränkt sind und das mit
einer sehr aggressiven
mietsteigerungspotenzial vor gefragt
wurde wer sind eigentlich jetzt die
gewinne dieser wohnungspolitik also ich
meine wo noria hat jetzt selbst im
krisenjahr noch ordentliche dividende an
die aktionäre ausgezahlt
also ich glaube da müssen wir
unterscheiden und ich bin überzeugt
davon dass ein sinnvoll ausgestalteter
mieten deckel
auch wirklich die gut wirtschaftenden
kleinvermieter ganz treffen wurde
aber es geht wirklich um diese
aggressiven wiederholungs strategie
gegen die großen konzerne zulasten der
bewertende mieterinnen und mieter das
sind meistens arme menschen ab und zu
lasten der allgemeinheit okay er geht
das co wie würden sie es bei beurteilen
als vor einem jahr der mieten deckel auf
initiative der spd haben sie gerade
richtig noch mal korrigiert ja sie wohl
ursprünglich initiative der spd und dann
durch die linken noch mal mit
aufgenommen herr gedaschko da gab es
ganz viel diskussionen hier in berlin
und sie ist es hier wird nicht mehr
gebaut und das ist das ende des der der
dass der investition und das hier
immobilien geht alles gar nicht mehr
welche folgen welche auswirkungen hat
denn jetzt zum beispiel der mieten
deckel konkret hier in berlin für die
immobilienwirtschaft
diese anmieten deckel ist so eine art
veto deckel weil die mieten werden jetzt
unter betrachtung der miethöhe des
jahres 2013 plus
dann betrachtet und das heißt man geht
78 jahren zurück in der betrachtung der
miethöhe und das ist etwas ganz anderes
als was sonst in der bundesrepublik
diskutiert wird das als erstes und quer
durch die bank weg egal wer der
eigentümer der wohnung war hat gesagt
das ist der wahnsinn der jetzt hier
ausgelöst wird weil es geht auch um
gemachte investitionen beispielsweise in
energetische sanierung zu bestimmten
kosten geführt haben all das findet so
in der vollen höhe braucht nicht mehr
berücksichtigung und das bringt
natürlich schwierigkeit mit sich unsere
unternehmen die deutlich deutlich unter
den mieten in berlin liegen oder den
großen städten werden 900 millionen euro
nicht investieren könnten weil sie das
geld schlicht und ergreifend nicht haben
wir lieben das heißt 900 millionen
eigenkapital sind am ende ungefähr
viereinhalb milliarden investitionen
sowie die in den nächsten fünf jahren
nicht investiert werden können und dann
vielleicht noch eins warum bauen bau
soll die lösung sein
theoretisch weil in dem moment wo ich
genug wohnung habe
würde jemand der sich am markt asozial
welt komplett ausfallen
aus dem spiel weil kein mensch würde
seine wohnung nehmen
wer hat das aber nicht ich will ihnen
vielleicht einfach nur mal sagen ich
hatte ganz am anfang haben sie mich
gefragt was brauchen sie denn als erstes
brauchen wir grundstücke im moment werde
heute einen b-plan jetzt im durchschnitt
108 monate das sind neun jahren
bearbeitungszeit so werden wir das mit
dem bauen oder bauen oder bauen dann
schon lange ganz gerne aber trotzdem mal
die fragen wie schafft man es dass eben
das meer günstigere wohnungen auf dem
markt kommen und da würde ich doch noch
mal gerne bei diese bei diesen mieten
deckel mietpreisen bleiben siebenkotten
wenn ich weiß als vermieter das steigt
nicht hört dann bleibe ich in meiner
wohnung dann suche ich nicht was anderes
dann gibt es einfach keine ungesunden
wettbewerber ist das so einfach aber
dann sagt die wirtschaft dann ist es für
uns nicht mehr interessant und dann
können wir das gar nicht mehr schaffen
neu zu bauen weil die anforderungen ja
auch enorm gestiegen sind also zum
neubau weil da immer wieder märchen
verbreitet werden zum neubau muss man
sagen dass alle diese instrumente
sowohl der mieten deckel als auch die
mietpreis bremse als auch die mieten
stopp initiative immer den neubau
ausnehmen der wird ausdrücklich aus nach
verlangen was ich möchte ein ja nach
neubau haben sie nicht sind unterliegen
sie nicht diesen grenzen die später
gelten sodass wie sinnvoll ist denn das
dann wenn ich also das wäre noch und wir
wollen ja ich will doch bezahlbare
wohnungen bauen wenn ich dann die neuen
können so viel kosten wie sie wollen
moment das ist richtig das muss auf die
dauer dann auch in das system übergehen
aber nicht in dem moment wo der neubau
gerade fertiggestellt ist und leute in
ein neubau einziehen erst zu einem
sprechtag kalkulieren ich muss doch
wissen wenn ich da was bauer was
investor deswegen wird auch nicht mehr
so viel gebaut aber nämlich sorge hat
dass man da rein fällt also die diebe
zahlen sind ja nicht zurückgegangen
sondern herr seehofer hat ja heute sich
selbst gelobt dass sie so toll gestiegen
sein
tatsächlich sind sie glaube ich um ein
paar tausend pro jahr gestiegen aber es
ist nicht die bauinvestitionen das bauen
ist nicht zurückgegangen das ist eine
mär
warum haben wir denn diese ganzen
geschichten
wie mietpreis bremse und wii mieten
stopp und mieten decke deswegen weil im
bezahlbaren bereich das ist das
eigentliche problem nicht genug getan
worden ist und weil man jetzt was tun
muss muss man das flankieren dadurch
dass man sagt in der zeit dürfen die
mieten nicht entsprechend steigen bis
das mal fertig ist und das dauert einige
jahre da das ist der hintergrund ja ein
mieter da haben sie völlig recht ein
mieter der sich in einer wohnung
befindet die noch einigermaßen preiswert
ist wird alles tun um nicht in eine
teurere wohnung umziehen zu müssen das
stimmt und deswegen die das ja auch
zurück waren umzüge bekam er von der
einen region in die andere und sind die
kanzlerin hat heute zwei zahlen genannt
zum einen für euro 69 in lüchow
dannenberg 19 eur 21 in münchen
da fragt man sich ja was ist denn mit
unserem gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnisse strack-zimmermann wie
kriege ich denn da gerechtigkeit rein
wenn ich in deutschland solche solche
gefälle habe das ist natürlich der
vergleich zwischen lüchow dannenberg und
münchen das ist schon ein sehr grüner
vergleich ich habe in münchen studiert
vor 30 jahren da waren war der markt
dort schon exorbitant das nur am rande
sie können das problem nur lösen
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse darüber
wird ja immer diskutiert sofern man das
überhaupt hinbekommt dass sie das land
um die großstadt herum attraktiver
machen mit öffentlichen personen
nahverkehr erreichbar zu machen dass sie
das digitale die digitale autobahn
auslösen dass man auch wenn man ländlich
wohnt unter umständen sein startup seine
firma dorthin verlegt oder dort gründet
das geht nur indem die erreichbarkeit
gewährleistet ist und auch die technik
so ist das nicht so bald sie die stadt
verlassen ende im gelände ist sobald sie
es schaffen dass unter umständen firmen
sich durch dort ansiedeln und die
menschen die für die firmen arbeiten
dort auch leben können werden sie auch
wieder infrastruktur dann kommen noch
die geschäfte so der adac nein dass das
muss natürlich nicht so sein sondern das
problem ist ja dass die ballungszentren
so teuer sind und es gibt ja durchaus
junge menschen die inzwischen überlegen
ob sie wieder rausziehen
aber sie ziehen natürlich nicht nach
lüchow dannenberg um das beispiel der
kanzlerin aber wenn ihr euer kabinett in
brandenburg wo tesla gebaut wird aber
das ist doch jetzt der springende punkt
fest ich sagen wir haben
19 jahrhundert man kann ja durchaus aus
der vergangenheit lärm haben unternehmen
eine firma gebaut
zugegeben aus politischen gründen die
ansiedlung der mitarbeiter mitarbeiterin
die wohnten drumherum das hat man aus
politischen gründen gemacht damit die
armen nicht abhandenkommen vor allen
dingen weil es wanderarbeiter gab aber
wenn heute eine firma auf macht und sagt
wir bieten euch das gibt übrigens firmen
die es machen auch wohnraum an
weil nämlich nicht nur das gehalt eine
relevanz hat sondern finde ich eine
wohnung kann ich die wohnung auch
wechseln wenn sie als junger mensch in
einer ein zimmer wohnung wohnt dann
kommt der partner die partnerin dazu
zwei zimmern hat man ein kind hätte man
vielleicht gern 13 gesunde wohnungsmarkt
muss natürlich sich auch bewegen können
und ältere menschen die einander zu
großen wohnung leben
die auch gerne wieder in eine kleinere
rollen wollen dann natürlich auch
weniger bezahlen um in die kleine
relativ gesehen das zu teuer ist ja aber
das ist aber das würde ja mehr dafür
sprechen dass man wohnung ja auch den
wohnungsmarkt mehr steuern muss dass man
sagt jemand dazu große wohnung voll wäre
das in ihrem sinne das war ja ist bei
genossenschaften sodass man teilen kann
dass man sagt ja wenn jetzt ältere leute
120 quadratmeter wohnung alleine bewohnt
dann ist es eigentlich nicht mehr sozial
dann sollen die die wohnung frei machen
für die familie mit zwei kindern sollte
es da mehr steuerung gebe also ich würde
ihn da kann ich würde ihnen da keine
vorschriften machen aber ich glaube dass
wir es ermöglichen sollen diese
möglichkeit nach wohnungstausch denn
häufig ist es ja so dass seniorinnen und
senioren auch gerne umziehen wurden
werden zum beispiel die farben
ausgestorben ist sich dann kleinere
wohnung wünschen aber die dann teurer
ist als die große wohnung die sie noch
beleben in der dann vielleicht der alte
mietvertrag hinten könnte vielleicht
eine größere wohnung also diese
möglichkeiten von wohnungstausch die
sollte man in jedem fall ermöglichen
wann immer es geht in unternehmen bei
kommunalen unternehmen bei
genossenschaften aber auch bei privaten
so zum beispiel das recht zu ermöglichen
auf zum beispiel den mietvertrag die
mietverträge sozusagen
also den alten mietvertrag ein zu treten
das ist was wir diskutieren was ich auch
richtig finde das andere thema was ja
jetzt auch alle vorredner in den
englischen wochen haben die frage wie
können wir eigentlich bezahlbar bauen
und ich will noch mal daran anknüpfen
was her gedacht vor fünf oder weide
gesagt hat die sich steigenden
baupreisen wenn wir uns die zeit seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg ansehen dann ist
wirklich ein großteil der gestiegene
baupreise ist zurückzuführen auf
gestiegene bodenpreise und ich glaube
dass wir hier wirklich ran müssen dann
dieses thema da ist hat sich auch ein
vogel den 70er jahren gescheitert mit
eigentlich klugen vorschlägen
da geht es beispielsweise zum einen um
das thema kann man nicht diese boden
wertsteigerung also diese leistungslosen
gewinne ein stückweit gesteuert
da gibt es die idee einer boden
wertzuwachs steuer ich selber könnte mir
auch vorstellen es ist eine art
bodenpreis bremse oder bodenpreis decke
gibt analog zum mietpreis regulierung
also das ist wirklich ein thema wo wir
ran müssen
denn bei diesen explodierenden
bodenpreisen da kommen wir überhaupt
nicht weiter weder für öffentlichen
wohnungsbau noch für genossenschaften
aber eben auch nicht für kleine private
die sich vielleicht selber etwas bauen
wollen
also das ist wirklich ein thema wo die
bundesregierung überhaupt nicht rein
gegangen ist und es wird höchste zeit
herr gedaschko fänden sie das gut würden
sie da der kollegin live von den linken
zu stimmen mit sagen eine bodenpreis
bremse weil die mit bremse ist er da
sind sie ja kein freund von aber von der
bodenpreis bremse können sie sich dafür
erwärmen
unsere unternehmen das bieten quasi
pleite quadratmeterpreisen tausche groß
gegen klein oder was auch immer
die erfahrung zeigt dass diese börsen
das gibt's dann auch wirklich im
internet oder für die älteren mitbürger
quasi als hätten kasten nicht angenommen
werden
in der regel werden größere wohnung
gesucht und nur ganz selten jemand aus
seiner größeren und aus und eine kleine
haben das ist also kann man an einer
hand abzählen leider
was sich da praktisch tut das ist
realität muss man einfach so wahrnehmen
dass die menschen so sind wie sie sind
und thema vorbereitet ganz wichtiges
thema ich glaube der und ist hier noch
nicht mal so sehr im fokus der
aktivitäten zu sehen das ist eine
zutiefst kommunale geschichte und es
gibt kommunen die machen seit urzeiten
eine aktive boden bevorraten des
politik- und ist gut die kommunen die
haben das nicht gemacht
und die stehen heute im kurzen hemd da
deshalb das ist eine zutiefst
kommunalpolitische geschichte ich selber
komme aus einer stadt da wurde aktive
bodenpolitik gemacht hamburg und die
stadt hamburg hat immer möglichkeiten
auch jetzt noch selbst nach dem sehr
sehr viele wohnungen gebaut wurden neues
bauland zur verfügung zu stellen und
zwar nicht zum höchstpreis sondern bei
einem wohl damit ein system zu 70
prozent dann der inhalt zählt nur noch
30 prozent der preis also das ist etwas
was in diesen passieren muss dass der
bund dort eingreift und die
vorgeschlagen den dingen macht finde ich
ein bisschen schwierig okay ich denke
das wird häufig gesagt wir sollen von
bienen lernen herrn wien ist es genau
diese aktive bodenpolitik die dazu
führen dass man bezahlt war bauen kann
okay das ist er raus reaktive wohnt und
krieg und das erleben wir auch dass die
kommunen die grundstücke nicht im
höchstpreis verfahren vergeben
dh dass der kämpfer sich das ja das war
einem einen punkt also wurde der
richtigen somalia gerne aufgreifen was
ist schon wichtig die kommunen können
und das machen wir in düsseldorf jetzt
verstärkt städtische grundstücke nicht
mehr verkaufen sondern eine erbpacht
weitergeben damit genau der preis eben
nicht umgelegt wird weil sie werden an
den bodenpreis wenig machen können aber
da können die kommunen steuernd
eingreifen das macht auch sinn dann
nochmal die steht es der bund kann den
kommunen ihm ein vorzugspreis diese
grundstücke auch überlassen das wäre
schon eine möglichkeit und das beispiel
hamburg ist spannend weil es hinkt ein
wenig weil hamburg hat die
landesförderung vom land hamburg quasi
in die
stadt hamburg umgetauscht während der
andere städte abhängig sind von einer
anderen vergleichbar
ich würde gerne auch mit einer immer
noch weil ich das spannend finde was von
links kommt entschuldigen ich kann mich
jetzt nicht in drehen also ja ich gucke
hierhin berlin hat jetzt tempelhof den
verkauf so das sind 300.000 300.000
quadratmeter das sind also weit über
drei hektar land da hätte man da ist ein
super park entstanden alles gut aber da
hätte man wenigstens mal eine
blockrandbebauung machen können also
sozusagen rein kreisen hätte man
sozialwohnungen bauen können von
feinster das heißt die linken die er mit
einer mietpreis bremse kommt weigern
sich dort wohnungen zu bauen
im herzen von berlin sorry das ist dass
er jetzt jeder okay ich würde gerne
heute 30 spricht ja so nicht der
wahrheit
der saß wie ein volksbegehren das
entspricht nicht der wahrheit ist ab
sofort online und was ich sagen möchte
aber es gab auch ein vorschlag damals
von der koalition aus cdu und spd
was eben eben nicht eine randbebauung
mit sozialwohnungen vorgesehen hat
sondern wo dass nur ein geringer teil
der bebauung sein sollte also ich glaube
das ist volksbegehren war auch
erfolgreich weil der vorschlag damals
von cdu und spd einfach so schlecht war
dass die mieten bewegung in berlin nicht
bereit zu akzeptieren und ende september
wird in berlin neu gewählt und dann kann
man ja gucken werden dass sich dessen
annimmt ich würde gerne auf einen punkt
kommen die für den mieterbund
sie sind mächtig in hier in deutschland
bedeute einen mieter land ist weil 60
münchen mit
das ist eine sehr das ist in anderen
ländern ganz anders warum haben wir so
eine geringe eigentumsquote und wie
sinnvoll wäre es nicht menschen zu
befähigen eine kleine eigentumswohnung
zu haben auch als altersvorsorge also
erst mal ich habe überhaupt nichts
dagegen dass menschen sich eine
eigentumswohnung kaufen also das buch
warum ich habe selber auch einen eigenen
habe ich nun sogar in einem
freistehenden einfamilienhaus das ist
jetzt kein grund sie eigentlich nicht
aber wir haben festzustellen jedenfalls
ist dass das was wir bemerken dass die
länder in denen es viele mieter gibt er
die prosperierenden länder sind nehmen
sie mal die schweiz die hat die höchste
mieter quote in europa wusste ich früher
auch nicht bevor es nach gelesen habe
das ist ja kein armes land sondern ein
prosperierendes land und irgendein
professor von der universität oxford hat
man festgestellt dass die länder in
denen eine sehr geringe mieter quote ist
beispielsweise spanien wo übrigens der
mieter so ganz am ende der sozialen
skala steht während er bei uns mitten in
der gesellschaft ist dass sie nicht so
prosperieren wie die wo es mehr
mietwohnungen gibt und deswegen finde
ich es in ordnung wenn jemand eigentum
haben will ich finde es aber auch
wichtig dass es weiterhin genügend
bezahlbare mietwohnungen gibt haben sie
auch wieder dieses land da intern
verteilt ist er reicht es schon dass
viele menschen in deutschland davon
träumen alle ein zu haben sie es haben
sich auch damit beschäftigen
da wir in einem freien land sind darf
gott sei dank noch jeder scheinen also
da bin ich völlig auf das einfache
entscheidende frage ist meistens
entscheiden einfach die geldbörse oder
die bank darüber hat die frage frau
strack-zimmermann inwieweit muss der
muss der staat das sollte er das fördern
jetzt gibt es das baukindergeld
interviews kurz was trinken es gibt das
baukindergeld da gibt es 300.000 anträge
es wurde heute auch stolz verkündet also
ist das nur sind das sinnvolle maßnahmen
dass man sagt wir versuchen dass mehr
menschen eigentum erwerben können also
auch gerne ein eigenheim das
baukindergeld ist natürlich ein
hilfloser versuch das zu steuern und
funktioniert auch nicht sie sagten es
gerade weil es wie immer so bürokratisch
in deutschland ist wie vieles übrigens
auch baugenehmigungen sind wahnsinnig
bürokratisch das heißt ich will gar
nicht messen ein volk der eigentümer
oder der mieter sondern die frage ist
was wollen die menschen und die menschen
träumen davon es gibt auch menschen die
träume von einem eigenheim detroit
tatsächlich ein eigenes ich gucke sie an
weil ich jetzt kann auch sie an drücken
die alternative der finger kann google
das weiß ich
aber ich wollte nur sagen die tatsache
dass wir in der situation ist ja ein
sehr ernstes thema museums wogen gehen
sie haben ja bei der anmoderation darauf
hingewiesen das ist was ganz
persönliches in der sich zu hause wohl
fühlt kann ein glücklicher mensch sein
und die tatsache dass wir in diesem
kontext eigentum das einfamilienhaus das
möglicherweise ökologisch natürlich
relativ viel energie frisst zum thema
machen dass leute diesen traum nicht
mehr leben können da frage ich mich wo
sind wir eigentlich inzwischen gelandet
ja die regierung könnte allein durch
eine steuerentlastung das nämlich heute
ist ja je nachdem in welchem bundesland
sie sind wenn sie eigentum erwerben eine
unglaublich hohe steuer anfällt und
erwerb steuern und die grunderwerbsteuer
anfällt die und wir haben seinerzeit
vorgeschlagen weiß dass bei der junge
familien bei der erst genutzten
eigentumswohnung eben diese steuer
rapide runter geht um das eben auch zur
unterstützung bei der ersten selbst
genutzten immobilie das betrifft gerade
junge familien die gerne eine wohnung
hätten und wenn ich das noch ergänzen
darf
es ist auch eine frage der
altersversorgung es gibt leute kaufen
sich eine wohnung um im alter mietfrei
zu wohnen ja also das hat er eine
sitzung aller komponenten her gedaschko
wie empfinden sie diese diskussion die
jetzt aufgekommen ist mit der frage von
den eigenheim wenn wir darüber gerade
jetzt auch in corona zeiten denken wir
vielleicht noch mal anders darüber nach
wie wir wohnen wollen wir merken dass
unsere innenstadt stellte lehrer sind
wir wir schätzen den eigenen garten mehr
also all diese dinge inwieweit welchen
einfluss hat diese diskussion auf ihre
ideen ja die auf die zukunft der
immobilienwirtschaft das ist so neu ist
das ist eine mär dass die leute dass
diejenigen die hier sind alle in die
städte ziehen wollen seit mehreren
jahren ist es so dass aus den 70 größten
städten diejenigen die dort leben
wegziehen es wird also das ist passiert
und es werden noch mehr passieren als
jetzt definitiv
wir waren aber eben bei der
eigentumsbildung und die
eigentumsbildung hängt auch zusammen in
einer vermögensbildung und wir haben in
deutschland eine vermögens
ungleichverteilung die ist schon
exorbitant und von daher lohnt es sich
allein unter diesem gesichtspunkt auf
eigentumsbildung auch noch mal zu
schauen und wenn wir darauf gucken wie
kann man eigentumsbildung für breite
schichten der bevölkerung machen muss
ehrlich sagen dass alles das was bisher
gesagt wurde zu kurz gesprungen
sicher ist es notwendig die
baunebenkosten zu begrenzen dazu gehört
die grunderwerbsteuer das aber nur ein
teil der notarkosten in holland ist es
beispielsweise so dass notarkosten
drastisch reduziert wurden wir haben
grundbuchämter die auch gebühren nehmen
und dann kommt eines es fehlt in der
regel am eigenkapital und warum schaffen
wir nicht an eigenkapital ersetzen das
darlehen das der bund gibt die auswahl
wahrscheinlichkeit ist extrem gering um
über diese hürde hinweg zu helfen und
dann könnten wir auch noch dazukommen
mietkauf modelle zu initiieren
etwas das diw hat hierzu einen vorschlag
gemacht es wird überhaupt nicht
gesellschaftspolitisch diskutiert alles
was wir machen ist so oberflächlich in
dieser frage der vermögensbildung der
eigentumsbildung es tut schon fast wie
wäre ein bisschen mehr phantasie nötig
klingt daraus frauen hassen diese erst
ich glaube wir müssen diese ich bin da
völlig beiden wir müssen diese
klassenkampf attitüde mal aus diesem
thema rausnehmen weil das macht das ja
sobald es ideologisch wird wird es
natürlich auch oberflächlich und nun
obwohl während wäre wer besetzt ist eine
ideologisch ihrer meinung nach die
linken vor allen dingen es wird hier nur
noch von kapital gesprochen ja es gibt
leute die verdienen sehr viel und auch
zu viel damit aber die meisten menschen
in deutschland haben eine wohnung und
vermieten sie wir müssen auch mal in der
relation dessen bleiben was in
deutschland passiert und wie gesagt ich
bin ja bereit darüber zu diskutieren und
auch wenn wenn so verwerfungen sind dass
man da reingehen muss ich bin die letzte
die das lustig findet aber ein bisschen
abrüsten
meine ich würde diesem wohnungsmarkt
roten und diesem thema reise fühlen sie
sich da angegriffen wie was das lange
www wie wichtig ist es dass man das mein
eigentum dass mein eigentum schafft und
dass der staat auch hilft dass man seine
eigenen vier wände bezahlen kann
nein also wie für mich da es nicht
angegriffen aber ich finde die fakten
sind jetzt nicht richtig dargestellt
also
hier her gedacht gesagt hat ist die
vermögensverteilung diesem land extrem
ungerecht und in den oberen zehn prozent
der bevölkerung über 60 prozent des
vermögens behörden und auch großteil von
wirklich auch werthaltige immobilien
dann ist es glaube schon ein thema der
gerechtigkeit was wir vielleicht hat
sich mit den mitteln der wohnungspolitik
lösen können
da müssten wir zu anderen themen
diskutieren wie beispielsweise eine
vermögensabgabe oder an der
vermögenssteuer
die ganze frage eigenheim eigentum ja
oder nein die sich heftig eigentlich die
wohnungspolitik seit den 50er jahren ist
immer wieder die losung ausgegeben
wurden
deutschland war mein historischen mieter
nationen so eine eigentümer nation zu
machen
wir müssen aber feststellen ist es bis
heute nicht gelungen obwohl es in der
geschichte sehr umfangreiche
subventionsprogramme beispielsweise mit
der eigenheimförderung gegeben aber für
eine barriere trierer sie sich auch
hinter war nach vorne listen ja ja genau
was während ihre videos wäre dass wir
das vielleicht nach vorne diskutieren
und zum beispiel über eine
wiederbelebung von modellen wie
beispielsweise dem genossenschaftsmodell
nachdenken denn wir haben ja durchaus
das bedürfnis auch gerade der
mittelschichten also auch nach
sicherheit und das eben nicht das
damoklesschwert beispielsweise der
kündigungen über ihnen schwebt und da
finde ich dass das genossenschaftsmodell
ein sehr gutes modell ist was ich eben
auch die unteren mittelschichten leisten
könnten und das attraktiv wäre
bei diesen massiv steigenden baupreisen
aber der prekarisierung von
arbeitsverhältnissen vor allem hier
einfach immer mehr leute raus die sich
überhaupt diesen traum vom eigenheim
möglichen können weil sie keinen kredit
bekommen weil sie das geld zurück haben
wir hätten trotzdem dagegen
diese eigenheim zu finanzieren und
deswegen finde ich dass wir eben über
solche modelle wie genossenschaftsmodell
danach denken können sind sie bieten
sicherheit auf der einen seite und sie
sind klein also hätte man eher aus
weiter es gibt sie ja dass hier bieten
sich ja genau und sie müssen die auswahl
und das meiner sicht auch im rahmen
seiner wohngemeinde zisch kite
steuerlich noch einmal stärker fordern
und privilegiert vielleicht bei der mine
verboten
siebenkotten und einer gedacht ja also
ich möchte noch mal aus der sicht des
mieterbundes sagen was mir ganz wichtig
ist wir haben überhaupt nichts gegen
eigentumsförderung das finden wir
durchaus eine sinnvolle idee
nur es müssen gleichzeitig genügend
mietwohnung da sein das ist der punkt
und ich glaube dass ich da zum beispiel
mit herrn gedaschko gar nicht
unterschiedlicher auffassung bin seine
unternehmen haben ja in erster linie
fast ausschließlich mietwohnungen immer
über die bodenpreise gesprochen haben
hat ja fläche nur einmal zur verfügung
ich fühle mich frage ist ja bei ich da
jetzt fünf eigenheimer drauf oder baue
ich da wohnungen für 30 familien da
würde ich erst mal wohnungen für 30
familien drauf bauen
nur man kann nicht hingehen und sagen
und ab jetzt darfst du kein
einfamilienhaus mehr bauen das ist
totaler blödsinn sagen dafür ist diese
fläche jetzt ausgewiesenen klar dass im
bebauungsplan reinschreiben
und ich bin auch ein fan von
genossenschaften genau wie frau leide
und frau statt zimmermann auf hilft
gerade höre das ist völlig okay
mir ist nur wichtig dass bei aller
eigenheimförderung nicht die mieter
förderung und die förderung des baus von
bezahlbaren wohnraum für mieter
vergessen werden sehe ich aber auch gar
nicht mehr so lange haben sie wollten da
auch gerne was zu sagen ja
an dieser stelle total einer meinung wir
dürfen das eine gegen das andere
ausspielen genossenschaftswesen gibt es
was wir uns allerdings wünschen würden
ist eben dass die genossenschaften auch
tatsächlich zum zuge kommen wenn es um
die grundstücksvergabe geben und das ist
leider häufig dann nicht der fall weil
sein können die kommunen diese zahlen
weil sie ihn für das klientel dich haben
und daran scheint jetzt ganz praktisch
das heißt eines rom ohne steuer wie
kommunale geschichte macht also ich
merke es hängt doch sehr am boden der
fabi nehme ich jetzt mal mit und bei den
genossenschaften sind sie sich hier auch
ein ich also das ist doch schon mal um
den kommunen muss man den spielraum
lassen und das wird die kommune vor ort
entscheiden wenn sie klug ist macht es
ja okay ich glaube die botschaft haben
schon alle gehört seit september 20 18
gibt es die wohnraum offensive
heute gab es die erste bilanz noch mal
dazu auf seiten der regierung wir haben
all die anderen perspektiven beleuchtet
vielen dank ihnen hierfür diskutieren
vielen dank fürs zuschauen morgen
schauen wir wieder auf unser thema
corona wir fragen warnung vor der
dritten wellen lockern oder nicht es ist
ja doch das thema was uns sehr
beschäftigt ich hoffe sie sind dabei und
jetzt geht es weiter mit phoenix der tag
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]